今天课堂的内容是先词后曲的创作范例
基本上多数的合作状态下都是先有一个demo
一个melody
然后笔稿的人再交出文字
用文字去入月
也就是填词
但我希望现在在听课的各位同学
将来都可以成为一个专业的作词者
有种创作的模式一定要能够掌握
那就是先词后曲
先词后曲的意义更好
处在于说有时候会有一些歌词创作大赛
歌词创作大赛基本上它就是一个定一个题目
然后所有人针对这个题目去发挥
把所有的内容围绕着题目去运转
然后再投稿
你投稿了之后
人家就看得出你有没有概念
不要说交出去的作品
基本上根本就不是标准的一个作词的格式
那就很糟糕了
先决条件的一个评委的印象就被扣分了
你可能就海选就被淘汰了
所以呢虽然这个圈内音乐圈
大多数的状态下都是先有曲后有词
但是我们还是要掌握一些作词的要领
也就是我们有能力先有词后有曲
那在分享范例之前呢
我来朗诵一首新诗给大家欣赏
因为听说同学们对我创作的韵脚师
还蛮感兴趣的
所以呢以后我每一堂课会朗诵一首韵脚诗
给各位同学分享
也希望课堂结束之后
你除了歌词创作之外
你也养成创作韵脚诗的习惯
因为创作诗可以变成作品集
可以帮自己留下文字
记录生活记录
而作词是跟音乐结合变成作品
这是两回事
但我希望你们通通都拥有
接下来分享的这首韵脚诗叫给你的信
手绘了几株茉莉
我将它画在秋千上
在细心涂上建成的粉红色
然后让他住在云里脱水干燥了几朵雏菊
就夹在你也喜欢的那本花间集
哦对了
用棉纸轻压收藏的
还有那些你呼吸声很近的俄语
你说你喜欢窗台那盆空气
凤梨那种不需要特别照顾的美丽
想到这不免还是有些小担心
你忘了我
撒娇时也像只需要被呵护的猫咪
其实我也想写一些有意境的诗句
而是纸上满满满满都是你
我找不到空隙下笔
唉亲爱的我这里真的没什么特别重要
非说不可的事情
除了想你
记得用不同的角度去看这个世界
你会得到不一样的视野
让我们一起感谢
感谢有挫折
感谢有伤悲
感谢我们还有音乐
感谢秋末后飘下的冬雪
让我们在这始终不完美的世界
还有纯白的感觉
感谢情人离开的样子
感谢一个人的日子
感谢这时而愤怒
时而沮丧的沉思
感谢我们
还有诗
让我们在这复杂多变且难以解释的心思
可以一一轻描淡写成文字
记得能创作是很幸福的一件事情
接下来就开始分享
创作上的一个先词后曲的范例
首先分享的是发如雪
通常跟周同学合作的模式
95%都是先有曲再有词
只有极少数先有词后有曲
所以呢等下分享的这首发如雪
就是极少数的一个范例
这是一个很标准的创作格式
所以标准是他的a one a two b one b two
刚好四段
看一下第一大段你们可能有点难以想象
这居然是先有词
因为基本上你看了以为是先有曲后有词的作品
狼牙月伊人憔悴
我举杯饮尽了风雪
我把狼牙月跟我举杯断开来
就是我在创作的当下
已经有一个旋律在脑海里面的
我是用旋律的节奏基金
以文字的段落很重要
因为先有词的作品一定是要入月
所以你填词的时候的段落就已经要想到说诶
对方如果拿到了十之后
他好不好
第一时间谱成曲
那我这样子的一个文字结构
基本上一字不改就能谱程序了
而且有时候可以帮助想
像所以我那时候创作的时候
我就很清楚的把它分成a one a two
A one b two
像他的a one是狼牙月
伊人憔悴
我举杯饮尽了风雪
是谁
打翻前世柜
惹尘埃是非
然后第二大段
所有的a two or字句基本上是一致的
原字诀
几番轮回
你锁眉哭
红颜唤不回
纵使青史已然成灰
我爱不灭
我的格式已经到什么程度
你知道吧
我已经到了A2
最后结尾的那一行
我还会变化之数
通常作曲的人这样会帮助他
因为他们的谱曲的格式可能是a one a two
然后A2要转副歌的时候
或A2要进入倒戈
在进入副歌的时候
它会有几个字句的音不一样
他不见得完全是copy a one的
所以我连这个细节都注意到了
所以我先有词的时候
我就已经把它改成
纵使青史已然成灰
我爱不灭他的秩序
你们透过屏幕上去看是不一样的
所以这个就是最专业的
先有词就是你的词的格式
基本上它入夜的毫不费力
好在一段倒戈
就是进入副歌前的段落
繁华如3000东流水
我只取一瓢
爱了解只恋你化身的蝶
你有时候倒戈不见得是完整的八小节
所以它的质数是比较弹性的
那基本上我去写这些歌的时候
就已经顾虑到作曲者的习惯和需求
而在进入副歌
你发如雪
凄美了离别
我焚香感动了谁
邀明月
让回忆皎洁
爱在月光下完美
第二段的副歌的第一行
跟第一段的副歌是完全一模一样的
这是记忆点
任何流行音乐基本上你可能变化的是第四行
第三行
但是第一行基本上都是一样的
因为音乐的走向它比较好去更改最后的收收尾
所以第二行的第一大段
你发如雪纷飞了眼泪哦
一开始是凄美的离别
这是纷飞了眼泪
像副歌那四个字
你发如雪
这个基本上是不可能动的
而且是记忆点
所以我都重复的去填词
重复的意境
让人家形成记忆点
流行音乐是这样
他跟古典音乐不一样
流行音乐有一个创作的格式
然后你去遵循这个创作类的格式
有个好处是你平常在工作的时候
因为它的旋律会有重复性
重复性会让你去记忆
所以你就会记住那些最有记忆的副歌
然后跟着副歌的歌词哼哼唱唱
这样子边工作边哼哼唱唱
其实很疗愈的
因为你唱出来的听觉
听进去之后会影响生理的变化
但是很少人工作的时候把古典音乐哼出来
基本上他没有词了
那就算你去恨他的哆瑞咪发嗦也很困难
他没有一个规范嘛
所以呢流行音乐他的魅力对于生活上的疗愈
他的重点就是在他有记忆点
还有规律可循
第二首先有词的创作
就是帮上海一个行政区叫江桥写的歌
一群人写自己的剧本
护林地震
将文化扎根走向世界的我们盖未来的陈江桥
浑血液里流的是真诚
因为江桥是地名
沪是上海的简称
而且里面有个盖未来的城
因为他们期许江桥可以变成
协助市中心发展的一个腹地
这些关键词是当地沟通创作的窗口给我们的
你去看他的格式
有种微笑叫江桥
他就是副歌
然后第二段有种微笑叫江桥
还是记忆点
那行政区不好记啊
硬邦邦的行政区就是人居住的一块土地嘛
那怎么办呢
好我用比较软性的词汇
这个聚会微笑
有种微笑叫江强
因为江桥他没有情绪
他就是地名
但是你把情绪的字眼配合名词加进去诶
听起来可能会比较不那么的生硬
好
接下来我们再分享副歌的部分
有种微笑叫江强
那第二段呢
这座城市有自己的歌谣
第二段副歌是写这块土地有家的味道去呼应
这种呼应跟对象是词句上的对应
然后第三行爱与拥抱比什么都重要
另外一段副歌的第三行
我们就是这文明的代表
然后第一段副歌的最后一行
我们温柔寻找那份美好
然后副歌的第二段有自己的格调
不落俗套
我这样子的歌给他们
基本上他们入夜非常的好发挥
当然这首歌跟发如雪不一样
发如雪是从头到尾我去构思整个画面
意境跟结构没有任何的束缚和要求
像这首歌某种程度上命题式作文
这篇作文的题目就叫江桥
那你要把江桥的特色
它的人文景致
它的风土民情反映在词句的段落上
这个基本上要收集资料
但是这个是因为专业合作
所以资料是他们给我的
有点像戴着假镣手铐创作
对我来讲反而很过瘾
为什么
因为我被束缚了
我被限制了
我被要求了
但是在这样的条件下
我还能交出自己满意的作品
就像一个物质极度匮乏的画家
还是尽其所能的运用周遭所能拿到的颜料
或者是画笔
完成了一座大家为之赞叹的创作
这个比起衣食无虑
环境很优渥的画家
创作出来的这背后的故事会更让你感动
这个就是创作的态度
不要去抱怨
将来有一天你们入这行的时候
我们新人的时候是从头到尾被要求的
有时候整段歌还改了好几大段
甚至整首歌重写都有过
那时候我就在想说重写就重写
因为我重写又有新的创意出来
那不同的创作呢
我就把它视同不同的成长和历练
这也是一种好事
就是你看事情的角度是什么
有时候难免有些限制
但是有时候创意就是在限制中成长
然后长成一棵你想象不到的大树
这个是创作里面最迷人
最意想不到的成就感
好的
接下来我们再分享另外一个范例
接下来要分享的这首比较特别
因为呢合作方他是把这首词拿去
争取让人家投稿
很特别吧
他先要求我把这首歌词作品创作好之后呢
他再用这首歌词作品去广邀大家去谱曲
那接下来呢我们再继续分享先词后曲
这首歌叫酝酿
这首歌的段落不是传统上的a on a two b MB two
它是a one a two
完之后有个BB完之后c one c two
第三大段才是副歌
它会让整个趋势就音乐的走向
格式稍微有点变化
就是副歌比较慢出现
这也是一种模式哦
而且很常见很常见好
那我们看l i two
第一大段是夜风低吟
穿越过竹林
然后第二大段的A2拱桥弯弯藤蔓
潘老强注意到有什么不一样吗
虽然一样是ELLA25
我换韵脚了
夜枫低音穿越过竹林
柳岸边
风稍停
风洞窗棂
你温柔明亮的心思波光粼粼
我脚步很轻
驻足聆听
第二大段拱桥弯弯藤蔓
潘老强
香气里的细节飘向何方
桂香月夜淡雅清香
影谁开窗
爱如柠檬般深情微酸
它段落是一样的哦
但是我换韵脚了
这个就是自由搭配的技巧
大家要灵活的运用
接下来我又换韵脚了
这首歌很特别
回忆起于燕往返的岁月缘分
在开头就写满了好几页相遇的情节
在古镇的夜里来来回回
诶
又换韵脚了
就是说连续三大段我换了三个不同的韵脚
是不是感觉好像比较特别
好像有柳暗花明的感觉
就是转了个弯
又看到不一样的风景
闻到不一样的味道
这是换韵脚的好处
但记得不要为了换韵脚而换韵脚
刚刚的发如雪是一个韵脚
到底也没有不好
接下来分享副歌
你将故事酝酿酿成桂花香
又换韵脚了
就是回到A2的韵脚
摇晃月光
笑影杯中的过往
我们聊着那年的远方
聊着照片里青涩的模样
4月换韵脚
但它的韵脚跟A2的韵脚是一样好
我们再念最后一段副歌
你将故事酝酿酿成桂花香
你会觉得桂花香跟酝酿是关键字
当初我写的时候让他们挑
我就写桂花香酝酿
后来他们跳酝酿
他觉得酝酿好像比较想看空间
那我认为桂花香也不差了
直截了当
有时候副歌是可以这样子的
就是多写几个版本
让对方去调
就合作方去调好
接下来我们把副歌最后一段念完
古筝清弹
思念落在青石板
与你有关的任何地方
我都将独揽为你而收藏
后面有个补了一句
因为有些流行音乐的副歌
有没有他唱完最后一段的时候
他还会再唱一句
我连这个都想到了
最后一句是共同抵酝酿一缕桂花香
记得你的创作目的是什么
就是要让作曲者方便入院
所以要尽其可能地想到他们创作上的一个需求
所以呢有时候我先有词的状况下
我一个标准格式就是LIA2b n b two
那你要避免几个错误
第一个错误就是说段落间的韩剧不能太悬殊
你a one明明就四行
你A2居然变成三行
你可以变成三行半或是四行板
就是再多一点点谱曲人
他还是可以办得到的
就是因为你字数少
他就拉音乐就比较慢板
拉长音嘛
你字数多
他可能就比较稍微光快歌的节奏去发展
譬如刚刚讲到的发如雪
我用这个在当范例讲解一下他的a one
狼牙月伊人憔悴
那你第二大段的时候
你就不要好像是你就硬写成云字诀
在几番的轮回就变成六个字啊
那其实是自找麻烦
而且为难的作曲者
既然你身为作词者
你要有能力掌握你笔下的文字
你就是将军
那些是你的士兵
你要有能力指挥他们前面的三行
或起码两行都不要去动它的质数
你要动的可能是最后一行比较自由
那副歌尤其是副歌的低昂是完全不能动的
所以先有词的时候
有些是规范
在字数的悬殊不能太大
你不能第一行三个字
然后第二大段的第一行七个字
这个就是诗的结构了
这个完全是不允许的
而且我也不认为进来这个班的同学们
会犯这种低级的错误
这是基本的认知
所以先有词要记住一个核心价值
我们是为了旋律服务
就像剧本是为了电影服务一样
剧本一定要人时地物
甚至有时候要写好内景外景
因为他是为了拍摄而服务
拍摄而服务
这个文字整理
只是他把文字整理成可以拍摄的段落
可能灯光师
摄影师看里面哦
这是日景
这是夜景
这是内景
这是外景
然后今天的演员有谁
人时地物全部都有
因为剧本是一剧的根本吗
根据这个文字
然后去开始影像化
所以剧本是为了电影服务哦
那我们的先有词的词是为旋律服务
就像音乐是为情感服务一样
大家都有需要服务的对象
旋律的节奏就像音乐的曲式一样
因为音乐在走的时候
他都一定有一个断点
好
我用发如雪来解释好了
像a one狼牙月伊人憔悴
我举杯饮尽了风雪
我之所以用3435
我就想象说他去谱曲的时候
他有一个音乐的断点
那个断点呢他可能可以三四音或三五音
那我不希望343是太对仗
因为音乐这样子有点无视
很自由
然后再来是是谁
打翻前世柜惹尘埃是非
因为前面的句子很短
所以我第三行就让它长一点
因为我听了很多流行音乐
所以我知道有些曲子是可以这样子走
然后第二大段源自觉几番轮回
你锁眉哭红颜
唤不回这个绝美
跟回他说押韵的地方
而这个押韵的地方相对于音乐
他就是旋律的一个节奏的顿点
就像我们先有曲后有词的时候
我们都把它拿到的demo带
把它听出来
把段落听出来
先词后曲的时候
你的创作的格式一定要很精准的
是必须直接可以入院的
而且甚至你还要帮作曲的
想到他有可能延伸的段落
今天这堂课就是跟大家分享
最重要的一个创作的一个核心价值
就是先词后曲的时候
词是专心的为曲而服务
所以格式一定要是很精准的
给入院